hey everybody tennis player here the
elphaba shoes hours 1/3 hour every
tuesday great issues of life I have a
terrific analogy for the importance of
the show it's the map if you have a map
and you know exactly where you are but
you have no clue as to where you should
be going the map is worthless that's a
college education for the most part
gives you a map of details but you don't
know where you need to go that's wisdom
there's a difference between knowledge
and wisdom so that's why we have the
third hour called the ultimate issues
hour and today's subject is science
scientists and others preoccupation with
the question of finding life on other
planets why the preoccupation I have a
theory but so does my guest well I don't
normally have a guest on the ultimate
issues hour but he's extraordinary Bryan
Keating is a professor of astrophysics
at the University of California San
Diego and by the way looking at his
title I was thinking if I could have
Dennis Prager professor of astrophysics
with Dennis Prager syndicated talk show
host I got I think the professor of
astrophysics has more cloud I got to
admit it I think that now between
professor of astrophysics and professor
of Gender Studies I'm gonna ask in fact
Bryan Keating right now and then I'll
tell you about his book so Bryan Keating
if you could have as title Bryan Keating
professor of astrophysics or professor
of Gender Studies what do you think has
more cloud
I think cosmic Gender Studies would be
interesting denom cosmic gender studies
yes that's right that's a very good
point
welcome to the show Bryan Keating you've
been on before and he is also done by
the way terrific prettier you course as
as an astrophysicist and a
what's a greater leap of faith God or
the multiverse has over 3 million views
at Prager eucom you should see it your
kids should see it in his book is one of
the most highly praised science books of
2018
it's called losing the Nobel as a Nobel
Prize it's it's terrific read and anyway
welcome back so there is there is this I
commented on and on the air and then I
think we spoke about it for a moment but
now we have a chance to really develop
it so I think we resonate that it's not
just science that is propelling
scientists to to look an obsessive an
over life elsewhere is that your take I
think I think it's it's not you're right
but I think it's not done in a conscious
way I have to say that for most of my
colleagues they are human beings and as
human beings they have certain biases
and one of them has sort of having this
blind spot as to what actually impelled
us on a day to day basis I mean do you
think about mmm you said you'd like to
be a professor but you know then you
have to come to the faculty meetings
right so I think I don't know you know
all right I'll stay I'll stay here yeah
all right better University faculty
meetings are much easier having been
approached Estrin makes them so
enjoyable but the but the day-to-day
productive patient on a scientist is not
to scratch you know his or her beard or
his beard uh and just ponder the cosmos
even in the case of an exalted you know
profession like you're making
astrophysics out to be I mean a lot of
it is is you know kind of day-to-day
what could a life or we're trying to
make incremental progress it's very rare
you have a day today you have a
breakthrough as a scientist in any field
and I think this notion that we just go
about our days you know kind of only
searching for truth and knowledge is its
fallacious just as it is for any person
that's you know ignorant of his or her
blind spot so in some I think think
you're right but I don't think it's a
conscious thing I don't think scientists
are setting out there are many though I
should say are
many know to write all right so when
let's say I asked 10 of these scientists
why are you preoccupied with trying to
find life elsewhere
what would they answer I think for sure
they would answer that they are doing it
for the search for knowledge and to
understand are curious you know fact
about the universe and understand as you
say I mean what could be more of an
ultimate issue than how we as human
beings came about and if that means
exploration of other planets as I hope
we'll get into or exploration of the
universe or as I discuss in my video for
Prager you the multiverse those are all
different scales that we can discuss the
you know that impel scientist to answer
questions out of genuine curiosity but I
do think for many of us there are biases
that lurk within us and those biases are
not purely of a scientific sort exactly
so let me just say for you you know my
my views but I just for my audience and
for you to respond I think a major
factor is the an atheist element and
that is ah you see we're not humans are
not special there is no God that made
the humans there's a purely natural
process that makes life from non-life it
is not a miracle it is not supernatural
that meaning above nature that has
produced it it happens elsewhere and if
it happens one other place it probably
happened in a billion other places
that's what I think is the animating
impulse I think that is I think that
certainly a subconscious animating
impulse I don't think again I don't
think they set out although there are
some and can talk about those who do
cherry-pick results and do you know fall
susceptible to what's the most
pernicious bias in my opinion which is
confirmation bias which all scientists
have to be on guard against and yet so
few of us are including myself all falls
prey to that as well but the bottom line
is that this confirmation this desire to
see any shred of evidence that may
confirm the a biogenic and you know the
the sort of life from non-life as you as
he put it
origin of
the existence of life-forms that they'll
latch on to that as they did many times
throughout or even recent history and
maybe we can get into it one of the most
famous experiments in science history
you know that's that's often used as an
example of the non necessity for the
existence of a supernatural creator is a
so-called miller-urey experiment well
I'm a hundred yards away from the URI
hall at the University of California San
Diego where Harold Urey worked and did
some of these experiments with his
colleague Miller in the in the 1950s and
60s and this is a Nobel laureate Harold
Urey and his authority conveyed a lot of
weight and it still resonates to this
day even after the findings have largely
been shown to have serious flaws within
them doesn't mean the overarching idea
is wrong nor do I think it's it's at
this tension that you can only you can
only subscribe to one and the atheist
will say that we you know who believe in
the existence or the potential even the
potential existence of a divine you know
a creator of the universe and of life
that they will say well that's just the
God of the gaps you cannot understand
something there's missing information
and so you pause it up in comes God but
you know in my work as you know the
ultimate gaps I mean there is no greater
gap than the gap between universes and
the so-called multiverse and I hope we
can get into these this notion that
people fall prey to the the love of a
theory or the love and the attraction
almost erotic attraction to scientific
theories well before they have any
evidence in their favor which the
multiverse is the best example of that
one well and also I mean just for a
moment on that the if I understand it
correctly and obviously you'll tell me
there can't be proof of another universe
because we have no access to it exactly
so when when we talked last a couple of
weeks ago on the occasion of the landing
by NASA the inside probe on the surface
of Mars you were curious about you know
what was the importance of this why are
they keeping to look for water what's
the relevance of this and maybe in the
next you know segment or so we can
discuss why is it so
important and what if it's not possible
even in principle to refute the notion
that there was life on Mars will
scientists stop believing in other words
it's not enough to not have evidence for
something but once you once you realize
that some primitives in principle
impossible to have evidence about
something do scientists still believe it
and I think unfortunately for the
integrity of science many my colleagues
do believe in things that it is
essentially impossible to ever rule out
and that is the fundamental test of what
constitutes science well all right we'll
be back in a moment
professor Bryan Keating professor of
astrophysics University of California at
San Diego
and the phone numbers one eight pregger
seven seven six what do you think
propels the movement to find water to
find life elsewhere eight seven seven
two four three triple seven six
hi everybody i'm dennis prager and this
is the ultimate issues our the third
hour every tuesday why are we why are
some people so preoccupied obsessed even
with finding life elsewhere is the
subject or one of the many subjects with
my professor of astrophysicist of
astrophysics excuse me at the University
of California San Diego Bryan Keating
his book losing the Nobel Prize one of
the hot most highly praised science
books of 2018 is up at the Dennis Prager
comm he also gives a pretty U course
with over three million views
what is a greater leap of faith God or
the multiverse before we go on I'd like
you to tell me about this I have a vague
notion but I had no names attached to it
tell me about the Nobel laureate who's
got a building named after him and what
was the experiment that he did in the
50s and 60s oh yes he was a Titanic
chemist who was located did a lot of
research at the University of Chicago
and then moved to UC San Diego later in
his life and won the Nobel Prize for the
discovery of something called deuterium
which is kind of like hydrogen's you
know heavy older brother and this this
scientist later on in his career to
develop a penchant for wanting to affect
Social Policy and this is sort of after
his involvement in the Manhattan Project
and I think part of it was to under
communicate both the you know the
fragility of human life life on Earth
and also wanting to agitate for social
justice we would call it nowadays in the
system it's not uncommon for scientists
to want to do that so here in San Diego
and a little bit earlier when he was in
Chicago he Harold Urey this is with a
colleague and they Miller I think
Stanley Miller he they devised an
experiment where they took gases that
were thought to exist in the early you
know prebiotic Earth's atmosphere so
we're talking you know probably three to
four billion
years ago on the surface of the earth so
they conjectured at that time using the
best knowledge they had what the
composition of the atmosphere must have
been like and then then they combined
that with a lecture static shocks given
into this atmosphere meant to mimic
lightning and they found that they could
they could create certain compounds
amino acids precursors you know that
many believe are necessary though not
sufficient to create life in the form of
DNA and RNA and sort and so forth and so
this was this is heralded to great you
know fanfare even back then as you know
an indication of what's called a
biogenesis so the formation of life
without requiring a predecessor life
form so the experiment was a later and
still is controversial it was
controversial amongst people that
believed in evolution and then pure
creationists debated the Swami and they
still do it was later found that their
methodology was sound but their
assumptions the initial conditions of
the Earth's early atmosphere were pretty
far off from what what they knew back
then compared to what we know now about
what the atmosphere must have been like
so the input you know was to a suspect
even though the output did produce
certain chemical compounds that could be
seen as necessary so again not
suspicions precursors to the formation
of all right you know what so I it's
funny I in the recesses of my mind I did
know I knew I remembered the lightning I
remember the primal conditions but I
didn't remember what the flaw was so the
flaw was that the more we know about
early Earth the more we understand that
those were not the conditions of the
early Earth
exactly right ok so that so have they
tried to replicate the experiment in the
with the conditions that they now
believe existed yes although you know
it's nobody had you know a gas
chromatograph you know nobody had who
was existed existed back then obviously
to actually assess what was the actual
composition so know what they should
have called me in I would have gone let
there be light and the issue we all go
home
it would be just as good in my opinion
you're pretty old
well no it would be it would be it would
have to be four billion years old and
then I would be able to judge whether
the conditions were appropriate it's all
right so let's go back to this search so
there there is a sense that again we
both have you as an astrophysicist me as
an observer of the world of physics if
you will and in astronomy that what is
the great compulsion to find life is to
sustain the the argument that you don't
need a God you don't need any
supernatural creator
it just happens randomly all over the
universe so is that what is propelling
the this preoccupation which is what we
talked about when the with the Mars
landing for water yes
so I'll take one step back it's
interesting to look through throughout
recent scientific history that kind of
the notions both in the direction that
you just mentioned you know scientist
attempting to find a non supernatural
God explanation for the origin of life
of consciousness of technology etc and
those that you know kind of parent
believe as do many faithfully you know
religious faithful that the universe
created by God and life itself was set
in motion if not directly directed by a
creator and this has happened so many
times I should say that the that the
this abiogenesis
a big fancy word which is broken down to
not but not biological genesis of life
there's a competing theory and it's
called I hope I can say this on the air
it's called panspermia it sounds dirty
but it's not don't worry I hope you're
falling you're okay okay good good good
so this was coined by none other than
one of the greatest scientists and
atheists of the the 20th century a man
by the name of Fred Hoyle and tan sperm
iya hypothesizes encounter distinction
to abiogenesis that life on earth
started because of life somewhere else
in the solar system or the galaxy and
and perhaps even beyond in the question
of whether or not that life
an origin that was a biotic was not
answered by him but Hoyle was an
interesting character in those times he
was a proponent of what's called the
steady-state universe which meant that
there was no biblical inspired or even
Big Bang inspired creation of the
universe he was a die-hard
opponent of that theory and in his
amidst his musings in cosmology and in
the biological formation of life he
would say things like the reason that
scientists believe he literally said the
reason that scientists believe in the
Big Bang is because they're deeply
attached to the theory of Genesis 1:1 I
mean today we laugh at that right I mean
most scientists as I say in my Prager
University video 70% of National Academy
of Sciences are are atheist and you know
so it's laughable will think that they
back then there were they were somehow
over smitten with the theory of Genesis
right let me just explain for everybody
the reason that this was Fred Hoyle who
said this yeah yeah is that Genesis 1:1
posits in the beginning God created
heavens and the earth in other word
there was nothing and something came
from nothing because of God so the Big
Bang sustains the notion that something
started but if you believe it was always
here you don't need a god we'll be back
they are the
all right you got to turn it down
because I get the transfixed by this
here dennis prager here the ultimate
issues our i I do pick the best stuff
for a cigar apparatus as well it's all
at the Prager store great great gifts
speaking with Bryan Keating not only
knows his physics he's a clear thinker
and these are delight to talk to and
read professor of astrophysics at
University of California San Diego so we
were talking we're talking about what is
animating what is the the propulsion
when there seems to be an obsession with
finding life elsewhere and even water
we'll get back to the water in a moment
I want to talk to you about the Big Bang
so Fred Hoyle his theory he lose it he
was as he I did not know this but it
makes sense because of his theories but
he was quite adamant about his atheism
so he believed from what you said that
scientists who believe in the Big Bang
are subconsciously channeling Genesis
1:1 because that posits a beginning and
the Big Bang posits a beginning him do I
have that correctly yeah okay okay so
what currently is the state if I pulled
a thousand astrophysicists in the
Western world and say and I would say
you have two you have two votes you
believe there was a big bang or you
believe the universe always existed how
would the vote go well I think
essentially all practicing cosmologists
believe in a in the Big Bang Theory I
did not know that yes I still but yes
yeah what's the but yeah so but the the
this spark that ignited the Big Bang if
you will that notion is is still hotly
debated that was the universe existing
in a pre Big Bang State or cyclical
state a quasi static universe of
a modern-day latter-day version of
Hoyles universe which instead of being
purely steady-state and stationary and
unchanging and global skills of our
cosmic history instead it did go through
epicycles throughout history alright if
well then then they'd have to vote that
they okay so they would say both there
was a big bang and the universe always
was correct okay right what is that
guy's into the multi-verse oh so you
really you put that in the same category
intellectually as the multiverse well
these are two hypotheses that are
diametrically opposed the multiverse
goes concomitant Lee with the
inflationary universe which stands in
Contra distinction to the cyclic
universe at this bouncing Big Bang Big
Crunch universe why they sound the same
to me what am I missing
so there's a difference between a
universe that always was but went
through uncountable cycle riding
collapse an expansion right versus one
that had a singular origin in other
words there was nothing 15 minutes
before not a universe collapsing in a
firing hellscape and from how but
instead it was it was nothingness right
okay so how many what percentage of
those thousand astrophysicists would
would say there was nothing before the
Big Bang great majority if that's good
if that's sort of if I'm using that
loosely as a shorthand for inflation
most practicing cosmologists believe in
inflation aka the theory that leads to
the multi-verse
most bad thing 99 all right I need to
say this on radio but I'm lost i I want
to understand this it doesn't sound then
like anybody believes there was nothing
before the Big Bang inflationary or the
other or whatever you're saying it's
it's still continuous no no no inflation
there's there's a single beginning of
the universe that we inhabit there may
be other universes within the multiverse
but beyond that if you if you try to go
back we believe our universe is thirteen
billion seven hundred ninety nine
million years old
if you go back an extra you know 100
million years you
there would be nothing oh okay all right
that's what I'm asking - oh okay then so
I'm confusing inflationary with
recurring yes cyclic yes cyclic is not
inflationary exact inflationary okay
good it's totally clear to me now
so so that I did not expect that answer
so in effect most that's roof is assists
believe what I the believer in Genesis
one believes in exactly and that
according to people like oil makes
writes the scientist will be back
[Music]
with 60% of the goal alright dennis
prager here it's the ultimate issues our
third hour every Tuesday life on other
planets what animates the the compulsion
there everybody's curious but some are
more obsessed than others my guest is a
thinker as well as a scientist and they
are not the same things it's not an
insult not the same thing is almost any
profession why oh yes he's a professor I
was reading why are science so obsessed
scientist so obsessed that's what we're
talking about professor of astrophysics
at University of California San Diego
Brian keeping his book looking excuse me
in losing the Nobel Prizes up at dennis
prager calm and he has a great video on
what's more rational the multiverse are
gone at Prager University
dot-com so we're talking about the Big
Bang Brian keeping and what would your
colleagues say to me if I said well
since you deposit something came from
nothing why doesn't simple logic suggest
that since we have no parallel for that
in our universe something always comes
from something
why do you rule out the possibility of a
creative intelligence that is
responsible yeah it's a very good
question I think you know along the
lines of what Fred Hoyle said I think
that there's a deep you know
psychological effect that's going on in
terms of science scientists unwilling
whether or not it's because they believe
that science is essentially their god as
many do as many as many from the great
Albert Einstein on down modern is the
modern era do you believe and you know I
was actually looking up you know on
Wikipedia you know which is not the
scientific journal but they did a good
job at compiling you know basic facts
but I read the definition of abiogenesis
from Wikipedia and folks can look it up
says although abiogenesis is
uncontroversial among scientists there
is still no generally accepted model for
how it takes place that's a sounding
isn't it because we don't know
essentially how it proceeded or what the
preconditions were what the initial
conditions were what the boundary
conditions are to solve these equations
and yet people believe it and that's the
same type of thing wait so that that
wait I didn't want to interrupt you but
can you read the first sentence again so
this is about this the origin of life
right online right the most important
questions in all of science right and
the definition in wikipedia says that
although abiogenesis is uncontroversial
among scientists well that wait wait
what what are they talking about they're
talking about the fact that most
scientists believe in a abiogenesis
without all helling is that true yeah I
guess I believe it's true just as most
scientists believe in the multiverse
Dennis I keep that oh no no I believe in
most weight the most yes I would say
most if they don't believe in it they're
not following the conclusions of the
inflationary theory and pioneered by its
founding father Alan Guth is a good
wonderful scientist a good friend of
mine he came up with this theory and he
also says that the multiverse goes hand
in hand with the inflationary universe
which is the one that posits also a
singular origin for the universe no no
no it's very painful actually because we
the average person wants to believe that
scientists are animated solely by the
search for truth and that they don't
have a prejudice involved they want to
believe that but I don't think it's
necessarily always the case there are
many scientists who are intellectually
honest and and I'm not saying that any
of them who do support these theories
without a physical model that underpins
its origins and mathematics that they
would require of any other theory you
know so for example you asked about
water all the time and water is actually
very common very common molecule
throughout the universe we believe it's
made up of the most common
element hydrogen combined with one of
the more common elements oxygen and that
makes it actually very prevalent
throughout the universe and there's a
theory that describes how the elements
themselves were formed it's called Big
Bang nucleosynthesis it's really again
all scientific words are at simple
meanings it means that it was how did
these elements get formed synthesized
and that is a standard that is the
standard gold standard if you like of
the theory it makes predictions that can
be tested against evidence and in the
case of the multiverse as I described in
the preggers University video we
cosmologists that practice in this craft
have no idea how to test it or even if
it's possible in fact to falsify it in
other words to not show that it's right
because that's not what we do you don't
want proof right well that's the Atheist
scientist science or the Atheist science
argument you can't argue for God because
you can't disprove it and whatever
cannot be disproved is ruled out of
science but you can't disprove the
multiverse but they rule it in they
believe it that's why I say which is a
bigger leap of faith that's why the
title is as it's given correct so the
leap of faith at a core and I think I'm
comfortable saying that I mean you are
you would not say that you can prove the
existence that is correct
well you said all the time you said that
many many correct I think the evidence
suggests it but I would never say I
could prove it right and you're open I
don't want to get the big impression and
scientists are all smug and full of
themselves and that we have a monopoly
on this hubris that we know we're
talking about because I often like to
take my religiously faithful friends to
task as well as you know that I believe
that if you're a religious person and
you want to know the mind of God that
that that you have faith in why not take
it a step further and learn science
because I do believe in the ideal world
science is the clearest path to
understanding the true nature of the
universe and if that includes you know a
god and maybe a personal God a
benevolent God etc then this is the
clearest cleanest path to it and I call
it a form of vitamins of faith that that
my religious friends and I have many
that I find that they that the
get turned off and they turn off their
their critical thinking skills just as
many of my scientific colleagues do and
that's a form of cognitive bias that's
susceptible and scientists are
susceptible as well back in a moment
with Bryan Keating
you
hi everybody dennis prager here speaking
with professor of astrophysics at UC san
diego university of california san diego
author of losing the Nobel one of the
leading science books of 2018 it's up at
Dennis Prager comm gives a pretty you
chorus on what's more what is it more
rational or more irrational which was it
but a bigger leap us a greater leap of
faith yeah God or the multiverse is it
got against God I shouldn't even invoke
God raksha's become Jupiter Jupiter the
you you mates you may be aware of
something this this notion that at least
is the popular notion that finding life
excuse me finding water elsewhere is a
great sign of the possibility of life
which which may be fine but I just you
made me realize I wish I had put two and
two together or all water is is hydrogen
and oxygen in the correct ratio yeah so
why wouldn't that be ubiquitous that's
right yeah it is certainly as I pointed
out you know it is to some call you if
you want to find water you can go to to
the surface of the Moon we've already
been there we've discovered without
doubt that there's water it happens we
in the form of ice but there's plenty of
water in our local solar system and the
probes that we send to Mars and beyond
looking for it if they didn't find it
would be a bigger surprise than that
they do so if you had to bet your
royalties from your book just throwing
out something absurd yeah do you think
there's life out there well you know my
book had to compete with a juggernaut
called the rationale Bible which came
out the same month as my bus though
royalties were greatly diminished I'm
sorry like I have like I don't I don't
believe they're in competition now there
were 10 to the 500 other books about how
evil Trump is right so the question is
if I had a bet if there is if there was
water on Mars as is the question
no no life Oh life
so certainly I don't believe that there
that there's an impediment to life
existing off the elements your question
for the whole universe but there you
know there could be life in the universe
there's no nothing that prevents that
from happening the question that I only
question I care about is if there's
conscious life and I believe the off of
that are extremely low if not almost
equivalent to zero and I've asked
several of my colleagues the most
prominent atheists who by the way have
rebranded themselves I don't know if you
know this they now call themselves
humanists and I think the reasons why
they do so are of interest but we won't
talk about that now instead they say
that the odds of life in consciousness
and cetera and the universe are high in
the existence of God the probability of
which would be essentially zero so the
odds of the multiverse being true of
life existing are very high to these
very prominent atheist such as that's
your lady Harold all right everybody
watch this video read his book Thank You
Bryan Keating it is a joy the Dennis
Prager show live from the relief factor
pain-free studio
[Music]
you